With Josh Mandel.
Josh, can you introduce yourself briefly?
Sure. So I'm Josh Mandel.
I'm a physician and a software developer.
And since I graduated from medical school,
I've been working on various projects in healthcare informatics with the goal of
making it easier for developers to build
new functionality that integrates into the healthcare system.
Sure.
So when the history goes back for me to about 2010,
I was graduating from medical school,
and as a medical student,
I had been very interested in making the computers do
more for me and for my classmates and for clinicians and patients.
And I had learned about this field of medical informatics.
So on my way out of medical school,
I was really excited to join a team that was just coming
together at Harvard Medical School on this new research project called SMART,
which was funded by a grant from
the federal government with the goal of building an app platform,
so building a way for developers to connect to the data inside of healthcare systems,
and present apps that doctors and other clinicians and patients could
use to make sense of the data and the medical records.
And when we started this project in 2010,
we really started from scratch.
We said, "What would a modern REST API look like for working with healthcare data?
What are the kinds of data we care about?"
And we made a list: medications,
problems at labs and allergies and so forth.
And we started asking, "Okay.
Well, what are the detailed data models?
What are the attributes of each of
these data types that we'd want to be able to work with?"
And, early on, we hosted some sample data that we put together,
working with a number of partners.
We integrated into a couple of
open source electronic health records systems to
give developers a picture of what this would look like,
and we held a competition asking for folks to build apps and share their ideas.
And we got great feedback from the developer community saying,
"We wish we had this kind of interface in the real world,
inside of real healthcare systems."
At the same time, when we had conversations with some of the health IT vendors that make
big electronic health records that are in production at some
of the major hospitals and health care centers,
the feedback that we got was,
"We're really excited about this technology,
but we're not going to go and implement a whole new set of
capabilities just to align with this research project at Harvard.
What we really need is a set of standards that we can agree on as
an industry to support these apps but also to support other use cases as well."
So that was about when I started getting involved in the standards development process,
and got involved with the development of what was then the very early days of FHIR,
the vast healthcare interoperability resources standard.
Sure.
So, early in the project,
we discussed a number of ways to improve access for developers to clinical data.
And we settled on a relatively small scope to begin with,
which was focused on building apps that could integrate with EHR and
mostly have access to read data from inside of the systems.
So data liberation, exposing what was in
those EHR systems and making sure that apps
could take advantage of those data and present a user interface.
And we were able to make a lot of progress by keeping the scope pretty narrow.
So the kinds of things that were left out of scope from the beginning
were being able to write complex data back into the EHR,
being able to integrate deeply with a clinical workflow
by restricting where and when an app gets presented.
We left out of scope
how multiple apps might run at the same time and
interact with one another through sort of real-time communications.
We left that all out of scope and said,
"Can we just solve the problem of putting one app at a time inside
of one EHR at a time with a consistent interface?"
And the exciting thing is because we were able to keep the scope pretty narrow,
we really focused on things that could be done without a lot of new research efforts,
things that could be built into the production systems in the real world.
We started to see uptake of this technology from some of
the biggest health technology vendors so that
now if you go to the healthcare trade show
and you look at some of the big vendor systems,
they are announcing support for and now they have support rolled out in production for
these capabilities inside of their health records that clinicians
use and also inside of their patient portals that patients use.
So we're really starting to see it become a reality for
these apps to get access to data and to be able
to display innovative user interfaces and make
recommendations for clinicians and for patients as well.
So we're at the point right now where our narrow scope has become a reality,
and it's very exciting to think about what comes next,
how we can begin to tackle some of those issues that we
left farther on the development queue.
Yeah, so one of
the great things about having a way to integrate apps with
the EHR is that apps can do practically anything,
anything you set your mind to and anything you can
display inside a window for a user to see.
But one of the challenges with apps is that you
have to know which app to run and when to run it.
And so, for example, if we have an application that helps clinicians make sense of
the bilirubin levels in a newborn infant and provide decision guidance,
such a child who needs phototherapy or other therapy or this level's normal.
If a clinician doesn't think to run the app,
they're not going to benefit from the advice.
So one of the big problems that we set out to solve was how
to recommend exactly the right app to the right user at the right time,
and even to look at kinds of integration
that might be a little bit less than launching a whole app,
but just integrating a snippet of advice or recommendations into the clinical workflow.
So the CDS Hooks project is really about that.
It's about watching what a clinician does while they're working with
the electronic health records system all day long and instrumenting that interaction,
looking for specific points in the interaction,
like opening a new patient chart or prescribing any medication or reviewing a set
of orders or lab tests that a clinician might be about to order.
We look for the specific points in the workflow, and we say,
"We're going to provide a way for external services to
offer their advice inline at those points."
And the advice could be as simple as a little bit of text for the user to read,
or it could be as rich as a link for them to click to launch a SMART app from
right inside the context of
their electronic health records system and really do a much more detailed workflow,
where they can provide some more inputs and get some advice that they can act on.
Sure.
So the Sync for Science initiative,
Sync for Science is a project that is focused on specific use case.
It says, "How can we help patients who
might want to share their medical records with researchers?"
Because the truth is that if you're doing a research study,
it's very easy to ask questions to your research participants.
You can create a form and collect structured data by asking.
But there's a rich history in the medical record that can be
very hard to obtain in a structured way.
It can be hard to obtain quickly or
automatically and without a lot of barriers in the way.
So, today, oftentimes, the way that a researcher
might get access to a medical record would be
either on paper by asking for
a medical record request and getting a stack of paper printed out,
or they might work with a hospital to develop a custom technology.
They might have to sit down and write special queries against
the raw database and try to pull out the fields they care about.
And both of those things are very slow and very expensive.
So in the Sync for Science project,
we've said, "How can we automate this?
How can we help patients share their data with researchers
in a way that gives full control to the patients,
but when a patient wants to,
they can automatically approve that kind of access?"
And it's a project that we've been running through Harvard Medical School.
There's a small technical team that's been helping to
develop a specification and some guidelines,
but we've been working very closely with the electronic health record community.
So we've been working with Epic and Cerner and Allscripts and eClinicalWorks,
working with each of these vendors to make sure they can build this technology into
their own patient portal products so that if I am
a patient at a hospital or clinic that uses a patient portal from one of those vendors,
I have a consistent way that I can approve an app to access my data.
And the cool thing is that under the hood,
we're using all those same standards that we've been talking about.
We're using the SMART on FHIR API to do that approval process.
There's an OAuth workflow using a standard set of
specifications to let a patient give access when they want to.
And then we're using the FHIR resource definitions
to be able to fetch specific kinds of data
like medications or allergy lists or lab results or immunizations and on down the list.
So it's been a really exciting project to see this technology
go from a set of use cases on paper or on our website
to now being implemented inside of patient portals from some of
the biggest electronic health record vendors in the country.
It's been a very interesting course for me over the last seven years,
which is to say, when I started,
I was pretty naive about the pace of progress and
I thought that things might move faster.
And the longer that I stayed involved,
and the more that I saw what it took to
really enable change inside of these organizations,
the more I've been surprised in
a positive way by how much we've been able to achieve in this time.
So the biggest leap that I saw us make was from talking about
this work as a research project as a cool idea about what the future could look like.
And if I go back and I look at the slides that I was presenting in 2010, 2011,
2012, they were really focused on this technology as a vision for the future,
but not as a reality.
And then if I look at what started to happen, 2013, 2014, 2015,
vendors started picking up this technology and saying,
"We can use this to solve real problems that our customers are asking for.
We can use this to extend the features that are electronic health records systems
have by really taking advantage of the wide market of app developers,
who have good ideas about how to work with clinical data."
So I would say that from where I sit right now,
I've been really positively surprised by
how quickly we've been able to make this progress.
And I think that a major factor in our progress has been keeping
the scope small enough to feel like it's not too far over the edge.
And so I'm talking to you right now from San Diego at
the end of a working group meeting
of the standards development organization, Health Level-7.
We've been here for a week,
working with folks across the world,
who are helping to define some of these health care standards.
And one of the big challenges working with a group like this is everyone is
really passionate and has
huge aspirations about what they'd like to accomplish in this space.
But there's always a very careful balancing act between what you would like to
see happen and what you can really make happen in a short time frame.
And I think a big factor in our success has been focusing on the sort
of short to medium term.
So predictions are so challenging.
When I think about the kinds of work that we've been doing,
it's been focused a lot on workflow.
It's been focused a lot on how do we put
the right app in front of the right user at the right time.
And I think that's incredibly important in today's install base,
where there's a certain way that EHRs look and feel,
and they have certain capabilities built in.
But, honestly, it's unrealistic to expect the base product to develop
these neat new sophisticated features in every possible direction.
So being able to open up that window and launch an app is really important.
I don't know if I'll predict,
but I'll say that I hope in 10 years,
this whole paradigm may be turned on its head,
which is to say, we won't necessarily be working with EHRs that look
and feel the way that today's systems do.
We may have very tailored systems that are focused
on the particular tasks that our user is trying to do,
and rather than launching an app from inside a system like that,
I think that the data will begin to become more of the central focus of the platform.
We're almost seeing an inversion of the control
so that rather than the EHR being the central focus,
the data will become the central focus,
and we'll be able to construct the kinds of workflows we need around those data.
That's a really abstract concept,
but to draw that home maybe a little bit better,
I would say that I hope in that time frame,
what we'll have is individual systems that
know how to take care of patients with specific diseases, for example,
and provide a really tailored workflow and experience for making
the right choices and incorporating patient preferences and
feedback from patients into that kind of workflow.
Thank you very much. It's been a pleasure.